was geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich habe
hier nach extrem langer zeit mal wieder
so eine kleine blog kann man gestatte
ich glaub nich kennt ja noch gar nicht
und das video beginnt mal so wie es
schon recht lange nicht mehr hatten
heute geht es nämlich endlich mal wieder
ums thema essen gehört sich gut an
leute wir befinden uns gerade noch hier
in meiner wohnung und wir machen heute
den ersten park von ich teste alle
influenza food produkte und lässt es
kann ein video ich teste infraserv
produkte die schlecht sein soll das war
aber auch kleidung das war alles
mögliche dafür gibt es auf jeden fall
auch in der fortsetzung ich dachte mir
nur wir machen mal mit food weiter weil
ich schon so lange kein essens video
mehr gemacht hat bietet sich das ihr
auch einfach an und starten jetzt hier
und morgen und fanden gleich ins büro
test noch weitere sachen die habe ich
alle in meinem büro geschenk das hier
ist doch schon das erste paket was wir
brauchen das ist halt ganz gut damit ich
so dass morgens auspacken kann weil wir
haben jetzt gerade halb zehn und zwar
kommen das von der markt gegen lifestyle
gmbh tue dann muss ich sagen und hier
ist eine toughe sorte und schau dort
geht auf jeden fall auch aus an max bei
dem habe ich das ganze ist ein bisschen
gesehen oder einige produkte die ich
heute auch testet wo alter ist ja
irgendwie ist er drin was ich noch sagen
wollte natürlich nicht alle produkte
aber max hatten 24 stunden influenza
test gemacht also überlege ich euch
immer wieder schaffe ich mir sehr gerne
mal abschicken
und wir haben hier jetzt einzig muss ja
schon sagen ich mag papa aber auf kaffee
drauf das war jetzt nicht so ganz
und so sieht das ganze dann aus hier
haben wir den markt geber gentlemans 500
gramm edition und netterweise haben wir
auch noch eine markt genauer pacers mit
dabei und extra obendrauf noch einen
kranken pavlov das gleich meine ganze
wohnung damit ich könnte mir vorstellen
als presse damit und danach vom latte
macchiato das mache ich morgen
eigentlich
reisten wir das ganze mal ausgerüstet
wurde das am 15 321 in köln ins kloster
ich glaube das kenne ich weiß wie das
ist das ganze kostet 23 euro also schon
ein bisschen teurer + 4 euro versand
möglich haben wir alles schon kaffee im
premium segment zeigt mal vielleicht
lohnt sich ja so kann man auch ehrlich
in ein video starten
wir probieren jetzt mal hier den
leckeren espresso trinkt ich sehr gerne
morgens mal
ich möchte auf jeden fall gut er marc
gebauer kaffee hat auch ein bisschen
mehr koffein als gewöhnlicher kaffee
oder kaffee wichtigen sonst trinke
deswegen ziemlich gleich umso mehr
schaffen leute das heutige video
entsteht mit freundlicher unterstützung
von nf in wassertiefen ist und wobei es
euch helfen kann
das erklärt mal leute bei einigen geht
es nämlich erst mal grob zusammengefasst
auch um das thema finanzen eure eigenen
finanzen um wie viel geld gibt man aus
oder eventuell hat auch nicht speziell
geht es aber um zinskosten und zwar
zinskosten für ratenkäufe zinskosten für
private kredite oder auch für
kreditkarten ich persönlich bin erstmal
kein fan davon schulden aufzunehmen oder
kredite aufzunehmen
trotzdem ist es manchmal unumgänglich
und so musste ich mir auf meine erste
kamera damals auf raten kaufen weil ich
eine 500 euro hatte einfach mal so ende
finden gibt es jetzt schon seit über
vier jahren zuerst in schweden gelaunt
und dort konnten sie bereits den
effektiven zinssatz ihrer kunden und
durchschnittlich 64 prozent senken das
ganze geht es mittlerweile aber nicht
mehr nur in schweden sondern auch in
deutschland und ich fasse ich das jetzt
mal kurz zusammen ihr downloaded euch
als erstes eine firma aus dem app store
oder place tor meldet euch mit eurer e
mail an und ladet eine rechnung ihres
kredites in eure ebwo wenn ihm ein code
alex 20 verwendet bekommt ihr sogar noch
20 euro rabatt auf euren ersten kredit
ende hin schaut sich das ganze an und
guckt ob man euren kredit vielleicht
doch irgendwie müssen besser hinkriegen
als ja bekommst du ein angebot das kann
es dann einfach digital unterschreiben
ende finden zahlt dann direkt einen
eigenen kredit ab und du bekommst
bessere konditionen die du dann halt an
nfn zurückzahlen muss für die dies nicht
verstanden haben kommt jetzt hier ein
beispiel du hast irgendwo ein kredit
aufgenommen sagen jetzt einmal 1300 euro
ihr habt euch also ein darlehen geholt
über 1300 euro und ladet das dann bei
einem hoch sozusagen bei diesem betrag
liegen die einsparungen zwei drittel
aller kunden
bei 42 euro also 42 euro haben oder
nicht haben und es geht wirklich sehr
schnell das ganze einzurichten der
variable zinssatz singt von 11,95 auf
6,22 prozent also ist dann deutlich
geringer und ihr könnt eure schulden
dann zu einem besseren zinssatz in zwölf
monaten ein ende finden zurückzahlen und
noch mal zum mitschreiben ihr bekommt
nur dann ein angebot wenn es in wirklich
teuren vorherigen zinssatz denken kann
sonst nicht also checkt den link in der
beschreibung sehr gerne ab falls euch
dafür interessiert vergessen ein code
nicht und wir machen es weiter mit dem
video machen wir uns aber noch ein latte
macchiato
[Musik]
meistens setze ich mich dann morgens
hier auf meinem sofa und schläft den
leckeren latte macchiato gucken bisher
youtube oder so auf euch ich finde es
einen latte macchiato kann man auf jeden
fall noch mehr genießen als ein espresso
espresso ist für mich erst mal kurz
nebenher das halt finde ich einfach ein
bisschen besseren geschmack und auch die
kaffeebohnen mache einen guten job
ich möchte auf jeden fall absolut gut
super lecker das kann nicht sagen ich
finde es ganz ehrlich ist nur meine
persönliche meinung 23 euro klar es wird
von hand wird auf die verpackung
geschrieben wird in deutschland gerüstet
so was kann man auch unterstützen ich
würde jetzt nicht immer so viel geld für
kaffeebohnen ausgeben aber hin und
wieder kann man das auf jeden fall
machen und das schmeckt wirklich gut
daumen nach oben von mir für dieses
wunderschöne café produkt was nach bevor
ich hätte mich zwar mehr über eine rolex
gefreut aber ein bisschen ein paar
förderung ist natürlich auch besser als
nix genau das kurze frühstück thurgau
war stimmig zum rewe wir brauchen mich
auf diesen bereitschaft den extra
bestellt aber man redet mit vollmond der
gar nicht angekommen da kommt der
nächste woche ein dass leute was geht
wir sind jetzt hier bei mir im büro ich
habe eben gesagt ich habe hier sachen
hin bestellt bzw lag halt sache unter
anderem diese butter bei und chips von
chris prob die habe ich im kaufland
gekauft ich habe die vorher noch nie
probiert hatte daher jetzt schon vier
sorten raus deswegen da bin ich auch
sehr gespannt drauf weil ich grob an
sich auf sehr sympathisch finde und ich
hoffe seine chips schmecken gut das
beste ist ich glaube von der hocke kam
diese sorte aus das ist friedberg
europe's chips wie sie sein sollten
aber dann bin ich gespannt jetzt habe
ich immer kurz oder nicht nur noch drei
von diesem schönen schüsseln besorgt
opaken habe ich übrigens 190 bezahlt
finde ich geht absolut klar er ist nicht
zu teuer
er ist nicht so günstig und das sieht ja
auch an sich hochwertig aus diese
packung mit denen hier sour cream bord
die sind echt riesig die chips frühjahr
welchem er extrem gerne von pringles
diese circuit ihren dinger da ja auf
jeden fall länger immer gespannt welche
sorte mir am besten schmeckte steht der
unternehmer die sorte drauf stehen dann
noch drauf lag am boden
sony hin steht doch immer ein rezept
drauf für einen blick den man selber
dazu machen kann baumann das hätte ich
jetzt mal machen soll
du kannst ja auch wenn du unterwegs bist
chips essen willst kannst ja auch nicht
und wir machen
ich möchte sehr neutral also ich
verstehe schon warum liebt nicht
schlecht werden und hier haben wir noch
ganz normal paprika das war echt dass
die chips so schön groß und man muss
auch sagen was verhindert dass später in
der schifffahrt noch so ganz kleine
krümel drin sind wenn die schon vorher
so groß sind haben wir gedacht wir auch
nicht schlecht
ich muss sagen bis jetzt sorgt dass
meine lieblingsorte aber schauen wie
weit die haben wir noch suite
bayerischen solche chips habe ich noch
nie gegessen
das riecht auch schon extrem nach
barbecue sauce die sind echt lecker da
würde ich sagen suite barbecue platz
eins auf platz 24 mio 10 19 77 oder
leger er verspricht ich feuerwehr das
wirtschafts aber mal wieder in meine
wohnung leute was geht ich bin
mittlerweile wieder in meiner wohnung
ich war in drei verschiedene leben dass
ich den reis gefunden haben
beziehungsweise die bio mischung zum
würzen von reisgerichten asiatische a
ich bin mal gespannt ob mir das
schmecken wie die spieler drauf man soll
das mit karotten und erbsen machen dass
michael nicht so gerne aber ich mache
einfach mal ein bisschen anders und
zeichnet das sind gleich bin mir sicher
es wird schmecken lässt ich bin gerade
voll in action ich zeige euch besser
nicht zu viel sonst gibt es wieder hält
weil oftmals wurden ja schon denn der
verlag sagt ich kann absolut kochen
mittlerweile ich schwöre ich bin echt
ganz gut unterwegs vor allem was bürger
angeht bin ich der absolute über master
das kann ich euch irgendwann mal zeigen
eine box schreibt mal hashtag burger
alle kommentare hier haben wir jetzt das
ungekürzt es kommt jetzt noch ein dann
muss das ganze 15 minuten noch so ein
bisschen vor sich hin brutzeln und dann
bin ich mal gespannt ich würde sagen ich
mach das noch und dann zeige ich euch
gleich das endresultat
wir probieren das gleich also leute rein
damit unschön gehirn ich muss sagen an
sich sieht das doch schonmal gar nicht
so schlecht aus nur ich weiß nicht ob
ich davon sachwerte deswegen waren wir
einfach mal die wo ist sie denn jetzt
die habe ich nämlich noch gar nicht
probiert wir haben schon diese anderen
beiden editionen vor dem einer salami
und das waren die andere mal ich weiß es
nicht aber die tun für spitzer kamen
glaube ich als sechs raus die probieren
wir jetzt auch noch nicht wir haben auf
der pizza sogar tomaten lauch zwiebeln
doch hier das gehört dazu zur natur für
spitze und halt thunfisch aber zu
erwarten habe ich so noch nie auf natur
fisch gegessen deswegen ich bin mal
gespannt ist ja auch die kaffee pads
ich zähle kapital den preis zwar nicht
so als den typischen influenza aber
irgendwie ist es ja schon sage ich mal
so ein produkt was man auch in diesem
format testen kann oder aber ich muss
sagen ich bin viel gespannt ob wir da
umreißt schmeckt auch leute das
dankeschön warte mal ich zeigt sich mal
eben könnt ihr das sehen in der kamera
auf jeden fall sieht das jetzt so aus
ich habe tomaten paprika ein bisschen
spinat reingemacht wieder dass ich da
gerne deswegen und jetzt erstmal auch
ich kann mir das auch wirklich gut in
einem rap vorstellen also so zum
beispiel ok gereiste ist so nice ich es
ihm jetzt wirkt das wird mega crash 9
ich meine heißt sowas messe schlecht
leider waren meine tortilla dinger halt
bisschen na ja die können wir nicht mehr
essen wird ist schrecklich aber trotzdem
mal ab hier ist riecht auf jeden fall
ganz gut ich hab nach gefühl bisher in
sojasauce rheinbach und terrier klose
wieder einmal ganz gut ist schlägt auf
jeden fall sehr intensiv vielleicht habe
ich zu führen also eigentlich habe ich
alles richtig gemacht
ehrliche meinung von mir ich finde auf
jeden fall lecker ich finde es ein
bisschen zu intensiv dieser also diese
gut so asia fahren die schmecken auch
immer sehr intensiv wenn ihr versteht
was meinem trotzdem hätte ich
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen weniger
gewürzt davon einfach reinmachen müssen
dann ist es beim nächsten mal weg
trotzdem auch ihre daumen nach oben von
mir gegen recht schnell ist gesund habe
ich nichts auszusetzen neun von zehn
punkte und ich muss noch mal kurz was
klarstellen ich habe beim letzten mal
ein bisschen gerettet
ich trinke dadurch echt viel viel mehr
wasser und mittlerweile gefällt mir echt
gut
ziehe ich jetzt noch bis zum anschlag
damit keiner meckert und ja an sich kann
ich das auch empfehlen ich habe
vielleicht den fehler gemacht der rest
ist an manchen stellen leicht angebrannt
dabei sind meine nicht vor anderen
kochkünstler doch wieder übergeschwappt
ich bin trotzdem so lecker dies gemacht
habe profikoch preis habe ich gut es
geht auf gegessen jetzt ist nach die das
bier ist nicht von mir das stand schon
als ich hier haben wir die
kapitalspritze schließt auch gut
ja ich mag dass rapids also lasst sie
gerne mal zwei minuten zu viel drin
jetzt benutze ich immer wieder diese
pizza schiere bekannt aus wir testen
eure lieblings amazon produkte oder ist
ganz schön fett die pizza halte und
leute was meint ihr viele von euch haben
jedoch wahrscheinlich auch schon
probiert ich muss sagen optisch ist das
jetzt keine zehn von zehn mehr aber der
geschmack zählt ja auch irgendwann dafür
zeit
ich bin mal wieder erich lecker auf
jeden fall
ich finde es ist zu viel teig dabei also
du ist wirklich zwei drittel davon ist
weil sonst lecker aber deswegen gibt es
sieben von zehn sage ich mal vorsichtig
jetzt habe ich den ganzen reis gegessen
die pizza also ich bin ja jetzt schon
sagt ist ja auch eine wilde comburg den
umkreis mit der capital kombinieren
und als abschluss gibt es noch einen
leckeren espresso aller marc gebauer
lecker 19
das war es eigentlich mit dem video
schreibt mir super gerne weitere
influenza food produkten die kommentare
für den zweiten part den werde ich auch
irgendwann noch raus hauen aber nicht
super g in den kanal daumen nach oben
wir auch leisten wir sehen uns haut rein